[Music]
what's very important I feel is that you
make a design very site-specific so in
other words there is not much
justification for putting a building in
a certain place that could be anywhere
else in the world
so what we developed is essentially a
structure that could get very dense in
areas where you want to keep certain
environmental impacts out like the Sun
for example or you want to keep the rain
out and it could open up in other areas
like over here where you want to get
prevailing wind into the interior of the
space so this is a very finely tuned
structure that can react even to let's
say a tree that is sitting next to the
structure so where a tree would provide
shade there's no need for the structure
to get dense so it can open up so we did
projects where we looked at a very fine
kind of tuning in terms of environmental
factors of a facade of a rectangular
building so it can play out in a small
scale or on a big scale but the
underlying power of the parametric model
is that it can adapt very easily if you
change the parameters so it's not that
every time you change something in the
design you have to redraw it but let's
say you know you turn the building a
little bit everything would adjust
automatically
I have absolutely no doubt that these
technologies will be more and more
important in the future and in a way a
project like this is a great case to
make for a new way of designing
buildings
[Music]